we now have a short statement from the
deemed oral health minister saying I can
confirm I've tested positive for
coronavirus as soon I was informed I
took all the advise precautions and have
been self isolating at home public
health England has started detailed
contact tracing and the department and
my parliamentary office are closely
following their advice I would like to
thank public health England and the
wonderful NHS staff who have provided me
with advice and support as your guests
have said Anna
Nadine Doris as a health minister is a
key figure in the response to this
crisis question of course will be asked
now about the safety of others in the
Department of Health and
parliamentarians - and maybe at the
kobra meeting we're expecting tomorrow
there may be discussions of different
measures to ensure there isn't a further
spread of the corona virus around this
key group of people who are trying to
one respond and lead the effort to
respond to the spread of the virus but
also those holding our parlament Ariens
and our ministers to account well indeed
and it poses all sorts of questions
doesn't it a given that politicians as
our guests were saying just now do their
business in close proximity to each
other they certainly do 650 MPs coming
from across the country you would wander
at the end of this week if other
parliamentarians perhaps have picked up
this virus are quite how far this could
all spread and of course what happens to
the Prime Minister - of course because
Nadine Doris was with him at that
international Woman's Day event what
precautions are there in number 10 for
the people in charge of the whole
country to ensure they are not
incapacitated and taken out of leading
all of this at such a key time in the
effort